minutes after midnight having been
kicked out of a bar in ilford Jordan
McSweeney began hunting for a victim
he sticks close by to this woman who
notices and runs into a shop to try to
evade him
he follows her
but then decides to wait around the
corner
she cautiously exits but he follows
she then runs away down a side street
with McSweeney striding behind her
she gets home and McSweeney returns to
the main road and focuses on another
woman here shown by the blue arrow he
follows close by and two passes by
appear to notice once seemingly looks on
in their Direction
the woman crosses the road but McSweeney
keeps up
she also makes it home it's then here at
this Junction where McSweeney and Zara
Alina's pass crossed McSweeney follows
her very closely for about half a mile
up that road they're captured on CCTV
three times then 10 minutes later she
was attacked just like those other two
women she was just yards away from her
front door
Zara was a bright aspiring lawyer who'd
been out seeing a friend when she was
killed prosecutors said McSweeney chose
to attack a lone female late at night
who stood no chance
he's single-minded he was going to go
for a woman that night
I didn't care where it was Cranbrook
Road is a busy road
or this was in the early hours but you
have traffic flow going through there
it's residential you have houses down
there you have CCTV down there but this
didn't put him off there are grainy
images of the attack but you get the
sense of the ferocity of the attack how
brutal it was and it was brutal and it
was sustained
McSweeney sexually assaulted Zara and
repeatedly kicked and stamped on her
body afterwards he returned his Caravan
parked at a Fairground site in the park
near to where he carried out the attack
the following day he is seen disposing
of his clothes from that night you're
under arrest
for raping murder of a female at
Cranbrook Road and the next day he's
arrested
McSweeney is a Serial offender with 28
convictions for 69 offenses including
burglary and assault he'd been released
from prison a week before the murder
vizara's family the trauma has been
incomprehensible even after identifying
her
even after touching her
dead body
even after burying her
it doesn't compute
we constantly stuck in a loop of
disbelief
constantly stuck in a loop of
images in our mind
about what happened to her the horror
that she faced
um the pain she must have endured we
live in a horror film a film they can't
stop replaying or questioning that night
there were women that were harassed
there were no reporting
there's a gap
in that relationship between
police and the community
it's that Zara's family want to fix to
help them understand how she was killed
on the streets she grew up on as she
simply walked home
Ashen her and agskinis in ilford